[Applaudissements]
ça marche à chaque fois bienvenue en
touche pas à mon écoute nous alors on
m'a demandé sur la présentation des
chroniqueurs je vais commencer c'est toi
qui va commencer d'accord alors j'ai
commencé par le premier il a critiqué
clubs de livres qu'il en a écrit ça va
bien mais on s'en fout tu vas faire un
quart d'heure sur le net continue
j'adore
on va faire une émission non une mission
après tout aussi en venir là qu'est son
du tajine
[Applaudissements]
unit4 est finie on continue aujourd'hui
d'autres capillaire de la téloche j'en
ai jamais
ensuite oui ensuite alors si lui est
temps de lui dans une victoire de toi
dans ton livre c'est qu'il va bientôt
crever
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la course a qui croient qu'elle passe
tout son temps à se coiffer et ben c'est
pas vrai elle se maquille aussi
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour l'hygiène matthieu delormeau
voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'est à dire qu'il a attrapé la
chtouille à marrakech attaque berne sui
pa chroniqueurs je suis l'animateur à
différentes interviews ont continué
parce qu'on a on dirait que ça t'a fier
alors la classe de 15 sur les oreilles
que j'en ai dans les couilles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
martel et moulins mais lente et de la
wii le suivant wiki sécurité a tranché
je les adore quand l'état russe est
compliqué très sadique site
gérard guittat et vont finir oui le nec
de public qui s'est perdue n'est pas
souvent que les contrées de choses que
les autres
[Applaudissements]
parfait maquillage bien s'arrêter
servant de coiffes
j'ai l'impression qu'on est en
répétition et pour terminer pour
terminer celui sans qui on pouvait pas
faire cette émission et pourtant je
préférerais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]